Value the life that is growing inside of their womb without shame.
Of illegal right is a protected entitlement to do something.
So by removing women's right to choose,
you are not conferring a new right upon women
that they didn't previously have.
You are increasing the maternal mortality rate.
You're increasing the infant mortality rate.
You're making it less likely
that women will be able to make aspirations
and achieve them.
You're making it less likely that women can get out of poverty.
You're making it more likely that women are dependent upon a man.
Making it less likely that women can escape abusive relationships.
You're forcing children to give childbirth children.
I just wanna make sure we're crystal clear on this point.
You are unaliving women.
The maternal mortality rate in Texas alone
has gone up 56% since its abortion ban.
Forcing people and children to do this against their will
is nothing short of torture.
This country would never enforce a law or policy
that increased the male mortality rate by 56%.
And even if we did, we certainly wouldn't try to disguise it
and dress it up as some kind of right for them.